it's valentine's day coming up in the
next couple days it's what i would call
valentine's day
weekend right so usually valentine's day
it feels like in the middle of the week
on a wednesday random but this is on a
monday so i feel like saturday sunday
people are going to be doing their
valentine's day thing so my first
question is um
where do you stand on valentine's day
you pro valentine's day i hate
valentine's day and where are where do
you have a relationship that's what i
kind of just set the tone of where
you're at with valentine's day in your
relationship the queen goes first okay
um i
don't have a valentine so maybe it would
be different if i had one but
i also feel like it's super bowl weekend
not really valentine's weekend
we're gonna be covering some super bowl
stuff today but yes well played so
um but i do feel like valentine's
is a little overrated like you should
always get your significant other
presents
um flowers champagne or like it should
be a weekly thing now when you say you
should always get your signature do you
mean the guy needs to get that for the
girl
or do you bring flowers and champagne
for your man uh miss queen that might be
weird okay so you're saying the guys
when you say you should always the guy
should always be doing that for the
woman i think so yeah okay
dr nicholson okay i do not have a
valentine and
there's a lot of guys in the chat
they're like what's up then okay
maybe this is my good time
just drop your numbers it's fine there
it is enter right now eric you're the
winner valentine's day is an enormous
pressure for men i've always thought
that it's this pressure of you have to
do the right thing if you don't do the
right thing you're going to pay for it
for the rest of the year these really
hidden ugly messages when i was dating
i have a lot of boyfriends
all of the time when i was dating always
the joke with the boyfriends was
we would let the amateurs have
valentine's day because we had a good
time all the time we were doing just
like victoria
yeah we're just like we're
always always always happy
and so like when it comes time that idea
that you have a one day a year
it's ridiculous to me okay plus it's
aquarius season and aquarius season is
about the individual it's not about love
really yeah well i'm an aquarius i just
had a birthday i turned 40 again somehow
um are you a peddler and what's that are
you a cuddler cuddler yeah
i could cuddle i'm not most aquarians
don't i'm breaking the mold y'all good
good um and uh mr tomasi yes okay
i do have a valentine i've had one for
about 26 years now let us know about
this bro let us know about this balance
uh well okay uh i have actually written
several essays you won't find them in
any of my books but i've written several
essays about valentine's day because
that's a very it's a very common uh
question i get right around now and um
usually it's uh what should i do how
should i measure a very similar what
you're saying as far as performance uh
and uh
how to sort of make her happy kind of
thing it's like this is the one day
you're gonna try to make her happy and
and this is like date night and it's
very contrived and i think that that's
the the i think the biggest problem with
having a special holiday for it it's
very contrived in the sense like well um
this is the only time i'm gonna do this
so this is when the expectations are up
on me uh the other thing is that it's
very commercialized too so let's just be
honest i mean uh i don't know if we have
the if we can call it up but there is uh
there's data on like how much the
average guy spends on valentine's day um
and then i think it's also
contrasted with like how much a a
regular like a like an average wedding
in the united states
[Music]